hey this is presh talwalkar here's a fun
question from the 2020 oxford
mathematics admissions test
evaluate the following sum
1 minus 4
plus 9 minus 16. plus so on until the
final two terms of plus ninety-nine
squared minus one hundred squared
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
i will present two ways to solve this
problem
first i will present the official
solution and then i will present another
way to solve the problem
to get started let's expand the sum so
that we can see the pattern a bit more
clearly
let's evaluate the sum of every pair of
terms
we first have 1 minus 4 which is equal
to negative 3
then 9 minus 16 is equal to negative 7
then 25 minus 36 is equal to negative 11
and so on now let's look at the
difference between these terms
the difference between negative 3 and
negative 7 is 4
and the difference between negative 7
and negative 11 is also 4.
so we can see we have a pattern
the sum of every pair of terms will be
an arithmetic series with a common
difference of four
to evaluate the sum of this arithmetic
series it will be useful to calculate
the last term
so we need to calculate 99 squared minus
100 squared
but this is straightforward because we
have a difference of squares
this factors to be 99 minus 100
multiplied by 99 plus 100
99 minus 100 is negative 1 and 99 plus
100 is 199
so this is negative 199
now use the formula for the sum of an
arithmetic series
we have the average of the first and
last terms
multiplied by the number of terms
the first term is negative 3 the last
term is negative 199
how many terms do we have
the original sum has 100 terms
and we've now paired off the terms so
we're going to have 100 over 2.
so substitute again we have one half
multiplied by negative three minus 199
multiplied by 100 over two
this is equal to minus 101 multiplied by
50 which is equal to minus 5050
and that's the answer
this is one way to solve the problem
i'm now going to present another way
we will directly write the sum as an
alternating sum of squares 1 squared
minus 2 squared plus 3 squared minus 4
squared and so on until 99 squared minus
100 squared
we'll use the formula
for the difference of squares on every
pair of terms
so we have 1 minus 2 multiplied by 1
plus 2
3 minus 4 multiplied by 3 plus 4 and so
on until 99 minus 100 multiplied by 99
plus 100
when we evaluate this sum
every single term will have a negative
one so we have negative one multiplied
by one plus two
negative one multiplied by three plus
four and so on we have negative one
multiplied by 99 plus 100
so we can factor out this term of
negative 1
so we have the opposite of the sum of
the numbers from 1 to 100
we can thus use the formula for the sum
of the numbers from 1 to 100
and this is
100 multiplied by 101 divided by 2. we
want the opposite of that and this
evaluates to be negative
5050.
so this is the same answer but derived
in a slightly different way
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time